all right matt and megan
where are you guys where are you guys
from origin um i'm originally from
indianapolis indiana
in pittsburgh pennsylvania and
how was your childhood you had both
parents one time yeah i
had grew up in a very nice family
both my parents are still married i have
a younger brother
you know i had both sets of grandparents
growing up um
pretty much was able to do whatever um
you know i wanted to do did a great job
yes absolutely
played sports played hockey my whole
life um my brother played hockey
traveled a lot as a family so um yeah it
was a
really good childhood and megan yeah
same uh
i have both parents also still married
um i have a huge family actually
i have eight brothers and three sisters
um yeah a suburban area
yeah graduated high school
and how do you guys end up down here
this is like
this is the opposite of the spectrum
from a childhood
that's a good question we ask ourselves
that every day yeah
um well is there addiction in your
family
no there's not there's i mean they drink
a little bit
but not so much like you know
yeah there's no drug use in my family um
maybe a little bit of alcohol but um
nothing with drugs
when did you guys first get introduced
to the dress
at a very young age for me at like
12 i was introduced to just like alcohol
but around my freshman year of high
school so like 14
i was introduced to pills and
marijuana and more alcohol
and then it just kind of progressed from
there my sophomore year
i started doing a lot of cocaine
and ecstasy my
junior year and then
i was actually sent to boarding school
my senior year of high school
all the way out in utah
and when i came back from utah that's
when i was introduced to
heroin for the first time mine was more
so after high school
um i always smoked pot you know during
high school but
never really anything hardcore um
but yeah after high school it was pills
obviously first and then
and was it your heroin addiction that
got you guys
together is that how you met yeah so
um we both came out here um
for rehab um we both came out here
from orange county um to yeah to orange
county first
for rehab um and
i i went through coming from indiana and
yeah they flew they flew us both out
here
they you know fly you out here not
knowing each other
yeah we don't know each other yet but
they pay for everything um
you know beautiful places like nice
rehabs
um and i kind of bounced from one to
another to another
and i was in the middle of a relapse
when i met megan and megan was still
in treatment when i met her
so yeah and what are you guys doing for
money now
you're living in a street number 10
right yeah we live in a tent
yeah what do you do for money um
yeah we boost we steal um
from shores yeah um
our parents send us money every now and
then um
your parents are your honor uh our
parents know that we're
in california in los angeles but not
that we're
living in a tent uh my both of our
parents would be
absolutely horrified to they wouldn't
believe it
yeah they wouldn't even believe it
honestly um both of our parents are kind
of
aware that we're not doing exactly what
we're supposed to
um but you know they don't know the
severity of it
um so yeah and what does your addiction
cost you like a week
um so we
about two months ago switched from
um about three or four months ago
about three or four months ago we
switched from heroin to fentanyl
um so we do straight fentanyl now not
any heroin
um and fentanyl is a lot more expensive
and so we probably spend 150 to 200
a day what's the difference in terms of
the high
that you get from fentanyl it's
basically the same high
except fentanyl is much
much more dangerous and a lot more
lethal
a lot more potent they say fentanyl is
like
10 times stronger than heroin
so we actually both got off
using a needle because of doing fentanyl
because we don't
have to shoot it anymore um
but you smoke it yeah we smoke it
so that's kind of a good thing but
yeah you get you know very drowsy
or you you nod off um
you know because of our tolerance we
sometimes
um really gain energy from it
um but yeah we usually spend around 150
to 200
dollars a day on on fentanyl
is that for the parent yeah no for the
for the both of us
basically it's the same routine every
single day
living down here we wake up we
hopefully still have drugs left over
from the night before
um you know we do what we can to stay
well
and then we go to work and work being we
go boost because we don't have
a car anything we have to use public
transportation which
you know takes the majority of the time
your time up
so we spend like you know six to eight
hours out
boosting and getting money um cashing
that
that um merchandise in um
and then we go pick up
and go back to our tent and get high
it's the same thing every single day
who do you sell the first desk to um
we sell it to different people um
there are people who will pay you yeah
um so i'm out
of los angeles um it's not like this
where i'm from or where she's from
but there's you know there's a lot of
people out here there's a lot of
different opportunities out here whether
that be
good opportunities or bad opportunities
and
you know you can basically do
a wide variety of things to get money
and so there's also
a wide variety of people that are
willing to cash in on
your addiction basically you know and so
you have a lot of
kids out here that are addicted to drugs
that
do whatever they have to to get high
every day and
stay well and there's people out there
that
take advantage of that and so um
yeah there's not just one or two there's
many many many people that
buy the merchandise out here so being
a white couple on the street you're
almost like a target for
a lot of people in this neighborhood
yeah for sure have you experienced yeah
for sure when we first got down here
um you know we didn't know anybody
um obviously being young
and white word very much targeted
they automatically assume we have a lot
of money they automatically assume that
they pretty much can manipulate us in
any way
to get what they want out of us
so when we first moved down here um
we were introduced to a guy and he
basically was helping us
you know he let us stay in his chant
with him for
about a month um he was
you know getting us by every day um
and we because we were so new we weren't
we
didn't know the ulterior motives behind
him doing that
and so we thought he was just a good guy
and being naive
you know people that we were at first
we continued to let him help us and
when we decided to leave him um
like leave living with him he got
very very upset um he said we owed him
money
and so he came and found us
was very very angry he was yelling and
had a giant
metal pole
and actually hit megan like three or
four times with the metal pole
um and then when i came back
he was still yelling and screaming and
um he hit me a few times um
but we ultimately had to pay 500 to
get out of this situation he extorted us
he extorted us
um and that's not um an uncommon thing
down here you know
and luckily
i was able to get that kind of money
um my parents were very
worrisome and wondering why i needed
so much money but
we did get the money we got through it
and ever since then we've been a lot
more
alert and aware of everything going on
around us
and so luckily we haven't let that come
in between us you know
um how old are you both of us just
turned 29.
yeah i actually um i've been to jail
twice
since we've been down here um the first
time i went to jail for
90 days and then the second time i went
to jail for
like a month and she was
bottomless
and she was um she was out here by
herself both times
um you know which is very very
scary for me because i know
what she has to deal with every day and
also when
i go to jail and my mind clears up from
all the drugs and everything else you
start to see how
crazy the life that we live really is
you know neither of us grew up this way
we've never known anything like this
and so we start to normalize
the things that happen down here and and
the lives we live
but when i went to jail and my mind
cleared up
it kind of dawned on me how
crazy and how pathetic you know
things really are yeah megan do you ever
have conversations
with matt about like what the [ __ ] are
you doing of course every day almost
yeah yeah we have we have conversations
almost every single day about um
wanting wanting to get out of here and
trying to get out of here
you just get stuck you know yeah yeah
look around
yeah it's um when we probably within our
first week when we first got down here
um this old man was crossed older guy he
was probably in his 50s was crossing the
street
and he said something to us and he said
don't get stuck down here
you know that happened to me i've been
down here for 27 years
and it didn't really dawn on me at the
time but
you know that that is what kind of gets
hap what kind of happens
because you get in such a cycle in such
a routine
and it's just every day is the same
it doesn't matter whether it's monday
tuesday christmas
it's all the same and it's just hard to
break
so do you guys have any plans for your
future
yeah so um we've been talking a lot
about um leaving california
and going back most likely to pittsburgh
where she's from
um and kind of building a future there
um you know we've kind of realized that
it's very expensive out here it's hard
to get by and so we've been
thinking about for quite a while um
that we would want to move back to
pittsburgh to kind of stay with her
family
and build a future there
um so when we first started dating
um not first but
we always talked about getting pregnant
i
um you know i've been in love with megan
for a long time
we've talked about kids i know that she
would be a great mother she has a lot of
siblings a lot of nieces and nephews
but when we were on heroin she could
never get pregnant
and it just never happened
and then about three months ago
um she started
you know throwing up in the morning
feeling very sick in the morning
every day um you know and just having
other symptoms um that's when we
transition
like transfer to yeah that's when that's
right after we transitioned from heroin
to fentanyl so
her body was off heroin and not shooting
out yeah not shooting up
and um so we found out she was pregnant
how far away like four and a half months
four and a half months have you seen
doctors about it
yeah and um it's one of those things
where
um you kind of you know
i think it was scary for the both of us
um
you know and also it kind of
is just an even bigger reminder every
day of
why we need to put action to what we're
saying
um but even at that
even because of
the pregnancy it still it still
sometimes isn't enough
to get us out of this cycle
and
their um yeah it's it's very very hard
um it's very hard to
it's hard to accept that i could be one
of those people you know
and especially just because you know
like
um sober neither one of us are those
people
um but
it's on drugs it's just another
um it's another story and
it's not an it's not an excuse and we
both know what we're doing
is not the right thing and
um even i know as a man i i should be
stepping up
and doing more but um
you know we both just kind of find
ourselves in
that cycle dude and it
it's sad honestly it's sad and it hurts
really bad
all right good luck with your future you
guys thanks